here you can see hierarchy viewer lets
you select from a list of devices both
physical and virtual on the left each of
which then contains each of the running
activities and applications running on
that device you simply select the
activity from the application that you
want to profile then hit the load view
hierarchy button here and you'll see a
representation of the selected
activities entire view hierarchy
represented here in the tree view from
left to right you can see that the
entire hierarchy is also shown here in
the overview and the layout itself is
shown in wireframe here clicking on any
view at any point within the hierarchy
will show you what is displayed showing
us the number of views which are
contained within the hierarchy from this
point onwards we can also obtain the
performance metrics to find out how long
it takes to measure layout and draw each
element of the hierarchy it's a powerful
tool and you can find out more about how
to use it to optimize your layouts and
views in the videos and guides link -
from the instructor notes below for now
note that we can use it to find
surprisingly deeply nested layouts that
need to be flattened for example here we
have a layout we could describe using
one of two techniques one solution is
using two nested linear layouts but a
better solution would be using a
relative layout the relative layout is
one level shallower another tip is to
avoid using the frame layout as the
route for a layout that will always be
inserted as a child into another one in
these circumstances the merge tag is a
better alternative as will be eliminated
when the layout is included into the
parents hierarchy to help you remember
all these tips and tricks Android has a
powerful static analysis tool called
lint as you can see here in the lint
window in addition to the layout
warnings we've already talked about it
also checks from everything from
accessibility problems missing
translations and hard-coded strengths
you can find all the things linked to
checks for at the developer tools page
linked to in the instructor notes